speaking of our ruling class speaking of
espionage
speaking of corruptions at the highest
levels of power in our society
jeffrey epstein's pimp jean-luc grunell
got suicided over the weekend yes he did
he got suicided real real good he
couldn't have gotten suicided any better
if he had dirt on the clintons oh wait
he did have dirt on the clintons
i'm not saying
i'm not saying
the clinton's had anything to do with it
i am told there were pant there was a
suspicious looking man in a pant suit
walking around the jail cell where
brunel was being held but i don't know
who knows who knows actually we don't
know who was around the jail cell
because there were no cameras whoopsie
daisy
jean-luc brunel who is he was this
modeling agent who really just
effectively acted as a pimp shuttling
girls to jeffrey epstein he would one
time he sent jeffrey epstein three 12
year old girls from france because they
were poor the families needed the money
and then apparently the girls were the
entertainment for one of epstein's
parties
this guy was held in a jail cell
because of accusations of rape because
of all these sorts of issues and he had
allegedly attempted suicide multiple
times okay so he there was a precedent
here for maybe he's going to eventually
kill himself
but for some reason
he wasn't on suicide watch that's weird
and they had you know guards walking by
doing checks making sure he was okay but
whoopsie daisy i guess
i guess the guards just weren't there
when he killed himself
and uh for whatever reason there weren't
any cameras outside the cell and uh well
aw shucks
there there goes that epstein
committed suicide allegedly jean-luc
brunel committed suicide allegedly
elaine maxwell prosecuted and as part of
the prosecution agreement they're never
going to open up that black book
to give us all the details
on all the very powerful global
specifically western leaders
who were involved in jeffrey epstein's
organization
where did epstein get all his money we
have no idea did epstein have ties to
foreign intelligence certainly seems
like he did gelane maxwell's father
robert maxwell was a well-known
intelligence operative
for at least one or two countries maybe
maybe more than that maybe
three countries even
so the whole thing is a little weird was
there state backing in the epstein
operation
what to we we know that when epstein was
was being prosecuted the first time
the u.s attorney at the time was told
by this was alex acosta right who was
then up for labor secretary under trump
he was told
no
uh
watch out about this guy he belongs to
intelligence it's a cost his own word so
that's kind of weird
and then whoopsie daisy
the main kingpin behind this suicided
the pimp funneling the girls suicided
elaine maxwell i guess she's alive
but doesn't look like she's going to be
saying very much of anything
nobody believes this
does
nobody believes
that jean-luc brunel
and jeffrey epstein just so happened to
accidentally be allowed to commit
suicide and whoops the cameras broke and
whoops the guards weren't there and
oopsy daisy they weren't on suicide
watch and oh well okay moving on no one
believes this
okay
we have very little faith left in our
institutions in the west
because those institutions have really
been hollowed out
in particular over the last 50 years but
we especially don't have any faith in
our intelligence agencies this is why by
the way when our intelligence apparatus
is trying to sell us a war with russia
over ukraine this is why people don't
want to do it
i think this is a major reason why we
are not eager to go defend the sacred
oligarchy of the ukrainians
in the name of freedom or whatever is
because we don't trust the intelligence
agencies we don't trust the state
department we don't trust the deep state
because the deep state
does a lot of shady stuff like this okay
they're involved with people like
epstein
according to u.s attorneys in america
and
we don't get the full story and when we
do get the story about what the ic is up
to it seems to be pretty bad stuff like
trying to like spying on donald trump as
a candidate
spying trying to undermine his
presidency based on complete nonsense
colluding with the democrats colluding
with russia actually ironically so we
don't believe them
when it comes to cleaning your home you
want a cleaning product that is safe
effective and affordable that is why i
recommend naturally it's clean a home
cleaning company dedicated to providing
the most effective cleaning products for
your home while reducing the use of
harmful chemicals their secret powerful
plant-based enzymes nature's solution to
cleaning when i say powerful i'm talking
about hospital grade enzyme cleaning
power they've got solutions for almost
every need in the house from the kitchen
to the bathroom to the laundry room this
is the greatest cleaning product i have
ever used
i generally don't do all of the cleaning
in the house but i do a little bit
usually after dinner i'll clean my cute
little buddies uh you know
high chair and i'm just telling you i've
used a lot of cleaning products this
one's the best by far my wife absolutely
loves it i'm encouraging my listeners to
start with four of their top products
conveniently packaged together in the
daily wire essentials kit for a limited
time our listeners can receive 15 off
their order just enter promo code
michael at checkout when you visit
naturallyitsclean.com
michael try these incredible products in
your home today shipping is free
everything is made right here in the usa
naturally it's clean get the daily wire
four pack today go to
naturalizeclean.com michael use code
michael get 15 off do not delay make the
smarter safer choice for your home
cleaning today with naturally it's clean
i'm glad you like that clip now
this is important
ring that bell
subscribe you'll get notifications you
can also head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcast subscribe to
the michael knowles show leave a five
star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you